though Ragnarok is almost a month away
to make sure fans are still excited
Marvel released the third international
trailer for the movie and of course it's
filled with visual goodies my name is
Sam Bosch and I'm about to dig into all
the hidden treasures this trailer has to
offer as per usual here's a spoiler
warning for Ragnarok d Thor trilogy
which is weird to say and the MCU in
general let's get into it there's some
new footage that wind pieced together
with clips from the other trailers might
just spell out an entire third of the
movie whoa which third be patient my
friends roll the trailer since a great
change in your future destiny has dire
plans for you my friend
I have dire plans for destiny
hello the goddess of death has invaded
us god I thought you'd be glad to see me
and this dead
it'll be reborn my image
need a stopper here to prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so putting together team
you'll date
[Music]
surprise this will be such fun
I am
he's a fighter
I'm not a cream
I'm the goddess of death
[Music]
what were you the god of again
[Music]
your timing sike let's just skip over
all this cool action because we've seen
most of it a few times now had nothing
to new except this extended shot of Korg
the rock alien from the planet Holt and
World War Hulk storyline see shooting an
awesome gun can't really beat that so
cool
I believe this trailer really lays out a
roadmap for a good chunk of thor
ragnarok when you add in all the other
trailers and whatnot one could make a
pretty good guess as to what happens in
the first act of this movie and there's
one element that really pulls it all
together before we get to that here's my
theory as to how the first third of the
movie will go again this is just my
theory and not to toot my own horn I
think it's pretty good I'm thinking this
story begins with Thor continuing his
adventure to find the Infinity stones
out in the universe he still needs
locate a bunch of them so now he's
focusing on the soul gem or stone
whichever you'd like to call it also its
last one we haven't located yet that
makes sense when coming to Odin for
advice he realizes that Loki has
banished and replaced Odin upon
realizing this Thor sets off to New York
City with Loki as his prisoner and based
on this clip and a few of the set photos
that have leaked Thor wordlist the help
of Doctor Strange cool is we get strange
given Thor that we're prophecy about
change and whatnot I'm being like Odin
does get discovered in that homeless
disguise we saw in those set photos and
Thor attempts to take him back to Asgard
but Thor learns the location of the last
infinity stone is in hell that's a
receive Thor all wrapped up in chains
trapped in the underworld from the first
teaser now my guess is that Thor is able
to break free from those chains with me
on there take out searcher he fails to
get the soul stone rats and barely
escapes with his life back to New York
but uh-oh slower and Loki Fixodent
delete freed someone next we see Hellas
back and she immediately does what she
does best
that's right kills well not immediately
first Thor freaks out and tries to take
her out fails and loses his hammer damn
that thing goes nuclear and possibly
kill some people say that's because in a
previous clip we saw hella is absorbing
some orange energy in the same alleyway
which could be that she's drawing power
from the people she's just killed either
that or she's absorbing the energy of
the newly crushed meal near oh what's
that face some of you might be saying
nah Sam those are different shots she
has her horns on now
when she is speaking to the army of
asgard they're missing so I'm probably
gonna guess that they're retractable in
who looking Authority get back up and
Heil hi Mandela take them back to Asgard
lickety-split they are scared when she
was deep powered she crushed me linear
so now that she's powered up she must be
terrifying however we now have a
powered-up goddess and she hitches a
ride and that's where we see the battle
inside the rainbow tunnel see Thor get
choked out and then is tossed out into
space
yikes my guess since loki is mainly
known for looking after himself he takes
nosedive right after Thor into the great
beyond and follows him to sick car but
he gets the better end of the deal since
we see him and the Grandmaster sitting
together in the same room cut to Thor
falling out of a wormhole and onto the
surface of the car the planet of the
whole BAM now we move into the second
act of the movie but not so fast hello
then arrives to Asgard banishing
Heimdall somewhere because he's
definitely probably not there when
Asgard gets barbecue Heimdall send away
and then we get the epic confrontation
of hell of versus all of Asgard I think
we can guess what happens after that and
there you have it that's what I'm
guessing to be the first act of the
movie maybe I'm totally wrong maybe I'm
half right but I think I've got some
pretty good guesses mainly because of
one crucial detail have you guessed it
yet to stores hair BAM for all the
scenes of Thor with this high-end type
pre boy haircut and you get a pretty
good sense of the flow of the movie at
least the first third of it but the
moment I wanted to point out is right at
the end no not Thor having lightning
pouring out of his pores the one with
Surtur shooting fire and nifty sword
that my friends and family would have
happened to stumble upon this video is
Searchers classic sort of you know or
sort of Twilight sort of doom sounds a
little sillier but it's more fun to say
they're probably not going to name it
the movie but why is it important well
one probably helps search or bring about
Ragnarok as I pointed out in previous
videos those flames that are bathing
Asgard have to come from somewhere and
two it's super powerful like it infected
the entire population of Asgard they're
you know gods that aren't supposed to
die with an illness without even
touching them and it reshaped all of
reality around earth and it all medieval
times should have mentioned that one
first is a little bit cooler than just a
really bad cold
basically the sword could easily take
down Thor Loki and basically all other
could he take it down search her not an
easy name to say we see Hope jumping
into searchers mouth ready to perform
some unlicensed dentistry on the fire
demon with his fists but something seems
off about these two shots the first one
being the international trailer
researchers torching what looks to be
Thor based on the cape and the boots and
from previous trailers we see a bearded
Thor bathe and fire better assume those
are the same scene but look at the size
of the demon compared to Thor now look
how big Hulk is compared to Thor in the
revenger 's line up shot now look at
hole jumping into searchers face as
searcher look better to you like if this
height floor could easily be at the same
height of searchers face but when Hulk
is attacked he looks like he could just
jump right into searchers fiery mouth
and in this movie Hulk is supposed to be
close to 9 feet tall wale was tall maybe
I'm looking too far into it but maybe
searchers power is growing after
cinching the beard off of Odin's son and
taken out Asgard so that's what team
Thor pulls out the big guns or big guns
just the Hulk well he doesn't have guns
in a sense these are just some stray
observations I had in some Easter eggs I
thought you guys enjoy but maybe I have
a few scenes out of order what do you
guys think how close do you think I am
to piecing all this together let me know
your theories and comments down below if
you want more thora breakdowns be sure
to check out my other two Thor videos on
this channel and while you're at it why
don't I give this video like subscribe
the new rock stars for more content and
check out all of our other breakdowns
Rick and Morty Game of Thrones you name
it we got it all so make sure you follow
me on twitter at sam badger so we can
continue this conversation and i'll see
you guys next time